رئيس الوزراء البريطانيه سابق بوليسيونسون
يتهم قوتي بتحديده بالقتل بصاروخ
اذا نشبت الحرب فلن تنجو اوروبا وستدفع
الثمن غاليا روسيا تحضر اسلحه متطوره
ومرعبه للرد على الدبابات اوروبا والميتان
الاوكراني هو الحكم كيف لا تكتفي
بالدبابات وتطلب سلاح اخر على وجه السرعه
الاتحاد الاوروبي يتخلفوا مع امريكا ضد
الصين
تتمدد في الحديقه الخلفيه لامريكا والزعيم
الكوري يعلن عن خليفه لكن ماذا عن زوجتي
وشقيقته والمقاومه الفلسطينيه
[موسيقى]
لقواتنا ضدكم فانتم اهدافم مشروعه لنا
الكيان الاسرائيلي يضرب ايران وزلزال يضرب
الاراضي السعوديه وبين العراق والمغرب
لليه تبدا بالعوده جاريه
رياح الحرب العالميه تقترب
الكل يتحضر والاصابع على الزناد والعام لا
يزل في بدايته الروس يكثفون ضرباتهم
وغاراتهم على اوكرانيا ليخرج الرئيس
الاوكرا منزل الاسكيمو
ان اوكرانيا بحاجه الى صواريخ بعيده المدى
من اجل ازاله ما سماه بالارهاب الروسيه
بينما تجري محادثات عاجله بينك يذبحون
فيها بشان طالبات اوكرانيا الحصول على
صواريخ بعيده المدى بحسب مستشار الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه ميخائيل بدونياك هل ستغمر
اوروبا وتدوس على خط بوتين الاحمر
لترضي وبعد قرار الغرب دعم اوكرانيا
باسلحه هجوميه هو الرد ياتي سريعا من ماء
برئيس مجلس الامن الروسي
الذي قال توريده الدبابات لاوكرانيا لن
ينقذ اوروبا اذا ما نشبت حرب عالميه ثالثه
اجرا الى ان حمايه اوكرانيا لن تفيد احدا
في اوروبا ولن تساعد العالم القديمه
المتهلك فيه تجنب العقاب
واضافا عدد الحمقاء في مؤسسه السلطه في
اوروبا لا يمكن ان يحصل لكثيرته وهنا نعود
الى كتاب المعارك الاوكرانيه حيث تسابق
روسيا الزمن لتتصفح اوراق الكتابه وذلك
قبل دخول الدبابات الغربه
القوات الروسيه في العمق الاوكراني
وبالتحديد بخموت واجلي داره الاستباق وصول
الدبابات الغربيه
امام خيارين لا ثالث لهما اما مواصله قتال
الشوارع الدموي اعماله من كلفه البشريه
وعلى الانسان
حرب الشوارع او خيروا الاخر الانسحاب
للحفاظ على القوه من جانبها نفس القوه
الاوكرانيه ذلك كالعاده قالت من الوضع
فيوجل دار صعب ولكنه تحت السيطره مضيفه
انها تتصدى لمحاولتي تقدم القوات الروسيه
وتكبدها خسائر كبيره لكن الجيش الروسي
يقول ان ما يعيقوا تقدم قوته في مدينه
اوغلي داره ووجود منطقه صناعيه تستخدمها
قوتك هذا كما واقعه محصنه ليتكرر سينا
الحصار في مصنع الزفستال في ماربل ومناجم
الملح فهل نشهد حصارا قاسيا للاكرانه مره
اخرى نحن لم نرى رد بوسكو الحقيقي بعض يا
ساده سلاح روسي مضاد لكل سلاح اوكراني هذه
المعادلات تحاول موسكو الحفاظ على اسبقيه
في الحرب الالكترونيه
جروبس عن انيابهم باسلحه حديثه ومتطوره
لرادعي اي هجوم اوكراني بالاسلحه الغربيه
في منطقه العمليات العسكريه في اوكرانيا
حيث يتم الان نشر منظومه فانصر اس ام
ومروحيات ميت ونيته وما خفي كان اعظم
يقولها الدب الروسي وفور رؤيه اوكرانيا
لتلك الاستعدادات الروسيه التي وصفها
الاوكران بالمرعبه ها هي تطلقون لا
استغاثه على لسان المتحدث باسم سلاح الجو
الاوكراني الذي قال انهم يسعون للحصول على
اربع وعشرين طائره مقاتله حديثا لكن
المحادثات تجاريه ولا اخبارها عن تسليم اي
طائره
لننتقل الى الولايات المتحده حيث يندلع
النقش حول التوريد المحتمل لطائره اف 16
لان اوكرانيا تستعد لتنفيذ هجوم لاستعاده
اراد فقدتها وبرغم ذلك اجري تدريب طيارين
اوكرانا على طائرات اف 16 وفقا لصحيفتي
بوليتكو
الصين تحاصر امريكا
تمضي الصين في طريقها في حين تتقطع طرقات
خصومها ومع تصاعدي التوترات بين الغرب
والصين يسير الاتحاد الاوروبي على طريق
امريكا لحرمان الصين من الرقائق
الالكترونيه
هذا التحالف الامريكي الاوروبي لملعب بكين
من الوصول الى اكثر التقنيات تقدما وخنقي
صناعه اشباه الموصلات في الصين وذلك بهدف
ضمان الامن التكنولوجيا المشتركه بين
ضيفتي الاطلسيه سيكسب ومن سيخسر اصحاب
العيون الضيقه كالعاده لهم الاسبقيه
بالرده ولكن هذه المره فين حديقه الخلفيه
لامريكا وتحديدا الامري الاتيليه هناك
تحولت الصين الى الشريك الاول او الثاني
لكل دول امريكا اللاتينيه بفضل التبادل
التجاري والاستثماراته في المنهجم والطاقه
والقروض التي منحت بفوائد ضعيفه نعم لقد
تغلقلت الصين في الحديقه الخلفيه للولايات
المتحده ويعني ذلك الاقتراب من الحدود
الجغرافيه الامريكيه وهنا يكمن التحدي
الممل اذا فكيف للامكان انت يؤمنوا
حديقتهم الخلفيه بعد ان صارت مرتعا
للتنانين الصينيه
خليفه
[موسيقى]
لا يظهر للعلم الا بامر منه وكثيره هي
خبايا هذا المجنون هنا هذه الطفله
المحبوبه لوالدها وهي التي لا تزال في
العاشره من العمر اظهرها كامل وهي سيكو
بدراعي والديا لكنها تتحضر للامساك بزمام
الامور في البلاد مستقبلا نعم مجله
التايمز البريطانيه تكشف عن خليفه كيم
جونغ اون اخيرا
وخليفته ليست الا ابنته جوئيه في بلد
يحترم الكثير من سكان مبادئ الكونفوسيه
التي ترى في شيوخ اولاد من الشباب
بالمناصب وتفضل سلطه الذكور اكبر من حكم
النساء برغم ان شقيقه الزعيم كيمياء هي من
اقرب الاشخاص اليه وهي اقوى امراه في
البلاد وهناك ايضا زوجته
ليست راضيه عن شقيقه زوجها لاخرج لهما
المجنون ابنته وكانه يقول ايه هذه هي
زعيمتكم من بعدي
الزئير الفلسطيني يربط الكيال
العين بالعين والبادئ اظلم هكذا اعلنت
المقاومه الفلسطينيه وبعد عمليه القدس
عادت مجموعه عرين الاسود الفلسطينيه لتؤكد
مواصله القتال ضد الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
وتنفيذ عمليات اطلاق نار على اهداف
اسرائيليه في المنطقه هذه المجموعه تتحسن
في البلده القديمه لنابلس وتضم عشرات
المقاتلين الذين لا ينتمون الى اي من
الفصائل الفلسطينيه لتتلقى تل ابيب ضربه
اخرى وما هو المندوب الصيني لدى الامم
المتحده يقول انه يجب على اسرائيل
الامتناع عن استخدام المزيد من العنفه
وحمايه المدنيين وفقا للقانون الدولي
مضيفا ان مجلس الامن غير قادر على ايصال
رساله قويه بشان القضيه
اسرائيل عن غضبيه لكن في ايران حيث نفذت
نجوم طائرات مسيره على منشات عسكريه تابعه
لوزاره الدفاع الايرانيه بقصبه صحيفه
غولسترول
الاحداث والتطورات
عزه مرضيه تضرب جازان بالسعوديه ووسائل
الاعلام السعوديه تبث فيديو يوثق اهتزاز
بعض المنازل بعد ان تم حظر سلاح عن تركيا
صنعه واصبحت هي القوه الحاديه عشر في
العالم والاولى في الشرق الاوسط لتصبح قوه
مستقله لا يمكن تجاوزها المغرب يعيد فتحه
سفارته في بغداد بعد ثمانيه عشره عاما من
الاغلاق خلال مراسمي تشيعه المدبره
المسبقا برازيلي يخرج من تابوتي اثناء
البكاء عليه وسط صدمه من اصدقائه واقاربه
هو السبب غريب نعم فقط من اجل ان يعرف من
سيحضر وفاته
اسياد لا تظهر اسلحتها عبثا ومع كل سلاح
تظهره اوكرانيا يظهر الروس ما هو اقوى
منها فما الذي سيظهره الروس ان وصلت
الطائرات المقاتله للاكران
[موسيقى]